the elon musk has talked about a
complete rewrite
of uh the neural net that they're using
that seems to again i'm
half paying attention but it seems to
involve
basically a kind of integration of all
the sensors
to where it's a four-dimensional view
you know you have a 3d model of the
world over time
and then you can i think it's done both
for the
for actually you know so the neural
network is able to
in a more holistic way deal with the
world and make predictions and so on
but also to make the annotation task
more
uh you know easier like you can
annotate the world in one place and they
kind of distribute itself across the
sensors and
across a different like the hundreds of
tests that are involved
in the hydro net what are your thoughts
about this rewrite is it just like some
details
that are kind of obvious that are steps
that should be taken or is there
something fundamental
that could challenge your idea that end
to end
is the right solution uh we're in the
middle of a bakery right now as well
we haven't shipped a new model in a bit
of what kind uh
we're going from 2d to 3d i mean right
now all our stuff like for example when
the car pitches back
the lane lines also pitch back uh
because we're assuming the flat
ro flat world hypothesis uh the new
models do not do this the new models
output everything in 3d
um so this but there's still no
annotation so the 3d is
it's it's more about the output yeah uh
we have we have z's and everything uh
we've disease
yeah we had a disease we had a disease
um we we unified a lot of stuff as well
uh we switched from tensorflow to pi
torch uh
my understanding of what tesla's thing
is
is that their annotator now annotates
across the time dimension
ah i mean cute
why are you building an annotator i i
find their
entire pipeline i find
your vision i mean the vision event to
end very compelling
but i also like the engineering of the
data engine that they've created
in terms of supervised learning
pipelines
that thing is damn impressive you're
basically the the idea is that you have
hundreds of thousands of people they're
doing data collection for you
by doing their experience so that's kind
of similar to the common ai model
and you're able to mine that data
based on the kind of edge cases you need
i i think it's harder to do in the end
to end learning
the mining of the right edge case like
that's where feature engineering
is actually really powerful because
like us humans are able to do this kind
of mining a little better
but but yeah there's obvious as we as we
know there's obvious constraints and
limitations to that
uh idea just tweeted he's like um you
get really interesting insights if you
saw
if you sort your validation set by loss
and look at the highest loss examples
yeah
uh so yeah i mean you can do we have we
have a little data engine like thing
we're training a segnet
uh no it's not fancy it's just like okay
train the new segment run it on 100 000
images
and now take 1000 with highest loss
select 100 of those
by human put those get those ones
labeled retrain
do it again right so it's a much less
well-written data engine
and yeah you can you can take these
things really far and it is
impressive engineering and if you truly
need supervised data for a problem
yeah things like data engine are the
high end of the
what is attention is a human paying
attention i mean we're going to probably
build something that looks like data
engine to push our driver monitoring
further
um but for driving itself you have it
all annotated beautifully
by what the human does so yeah that's
interesting i mean that applies to
driver attention as well
do you want to detect the eyes do you
want to detect blinking and pupil
movement
do you want to detect all the like face
alignments the landmark detection and so
on
and then doing kind of reasoning based
on that or do you want to take the
entirety of the face over time and do
end to end
i mean it's obvious that over eventually
you have to do end to end with some
calibration with some fixes and so on
but it's uh like i don't know when
that's the right move
even if it's end to end there actually
is there is no
kind of um you have to supervise that
with humans
whether a human is paying attention or
not is a completely subjective judgment
um like you can try to like
automatically do it with some stuff but
you don't have
if i record a video of a human i don't
have
true annotations anywhere in that video
the only way to get them
is with you know other humans labeling
it really
well i don't know uh you you so
if you think deeply about it you could
you might be able to just depending on
the task it may be a discover
self-annotating things like
you know you can look at like steering
wheel reversal or something like that
you can discover little moments of lapse
of attention yeah
i mean that's that's where psychology
comes in
is there indicate because you have so so
much data to look at
so you might be able to find moments
when there's like just
inattention that even with smartphone if
you want to detect smartphone use
yeah you can start to zoom in i mean
that's the gold mine
sort of the comma ai i mean tesla's
doing this too right is there they're
doing
annotation based on it's like uh
self-supervised
learning too it's just a small part of
the entire picture
it's that's kind of the challenge
of solving a problem in machine learning
if you can discover
self-annotating parts of the problem
right our driver monitoring team is half
a person right now
you know once we have skill to full once
we have two people once we have two
three people on that team
i definitely want to look at self
annotating stuff for attention
you